When running a Forest Model,
we're going to look for
a couple of things in the results.
These can tell us how solid the model
is, what factors are most important, and
possibly changes to the model to rerun.
The first thing to look for is something
called the out of the bag error rate.
This explains how well the model
performed with the cross validation set
in the estimation sample.
This gives us a good understanding
of how solid the model performs
with just the estimation data.
You can think of it in the same
terms as an R-squared value.
What we also look for
is the confusion matrix.
This shows again how well the model
performed on the original
estimation data.
Compared to the out of the bag error
rate, the confusion matrix does a better
job of representing where errors
occurred in classifying the data.
As you've learned when we're running a
forest model we're using an ensemble of
decision trees.
This can be computationally intensive.
So let's have a look at
the percentage error for
the different number of trees graph.
We can use this to help us see what the
correct number of trees is to use, so
we can avoid over computing.
What we are looking for
is the number of trees it takes to
minimize the error of each of the items.
So, basically, where does it flatline?
After we determine this number, we can
change the subsequent forest models
to run this data to the smaller
number of decision trees.
Finally, we need to look for
which predictor variables matter
the most in this relation to the model.
This is very helpful in determining
which variables are most associated with
their data and we can focus on this for
future analysis.
Let's examine this things
over in Altrix, now.